avec la force et la conviction du
maestro yannick nézet-séguin et
l'orchestré métropolitain de montréal
célébrer ses 40 ans 40 ans et la pleine
maturité
mais c'est encore plein de projets c'est
à peu près mon agent j'ai 46 donc on
suit un petit peu comme ça fait 21 h à
l'om
depuis 1981 l'orchestré métropolitain a
fait des pas de géant son succès ici
comme à l'international est lié à celui
de yannick nézet séguin pour le concert
d'ouverture de la saison 2021 2022 le
maestro misera sur ravel et sur une
nouvelle oeuvre une compositrice
anishnabe visiblement ému d'avoir été
évité je traite ce soir
c'est le pont entre les cultures c'est
toujour ete sommes à ma grande passion
et c'est ce qu'on véhicule à l'om
le temps passe et les succès
s'accumulent pour yannick nézet-séguin
cette semaine à new york pour la toute
première fois dans l'histoire du
metropolitan opera il a présenté une
oeuvre d'un artiste afro américains
c'est qu'on vous start-up blancheur d'un
grand compositeur jazz et de musiques de
film a fait un chef-d'oeuvre et c'était
plein de gens plus issus de la diversité
que d'habitude et c'est pour moi c'est
ça l'avenir de l'opéra et c'est juste le
début il y en a plein de projets dans la
tête
le pouce en l'air le maestro encore
beaucoup de pain sur la planche après
montréal il sera aux côtés guy horn avec
l'orchestré de philadelphie le chef
d'orchestre applaudi la réouverture des
salles c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup de
voyages c'est beaucoup de ces beaucoup
de musique d'un coup mais c'est sûr que
c'est là c'est là c'est la fête totale
parce que c'est non seulement de
retrouver l'énergie du public mais où m
comme à philadephie comme à l'om notre
priorité c'est de ne pas revenir comme
avant
wii fit donc oui mais radio-canada
mourir
[Musique]